I want everything to be perfect before
something happens that's how I am
I want everything to be look as soon as
everything gets all lined up
it's all perfect then this will happen
and by doing that I'm not really giving
I'm not really giving the Lord a chance
to tickle me you know I'm not really
giving and stay with me
I'm not by by saying okay I'm not when
as soon as this then this and then this
you know as soon as I get my slippers on
my feet will be warm
I'ma go to Daddy's I'm gonna make a pot
pie
you know it's but only I'm I ain't
having no pot pie to like do the other
thing until I do my you know
when I have my own plan Stay With Me
what I'm saying is I'm always I'm I'm
always waiting for everything to be
perfect before I live my life
I'm always waiting for everything to be
perfect
before I live my life
as soon as these things line up
I'm going to live my life
man I'm so guilty of that
you know it's you know
as soon as it as soon as you know this
new medicine I'm using helps me and as
soon as uh this shirt I ordered come in
and as soon as I learn Spanish that you
my [ __ ] I'll learn as soon as I learn
Spanish really well like I'm a you know
a blue belt or whatever in it but I I
always want to wait till everything's
perfect you know Dustin Poirier noticed
that about me
and he said to me Point Blank he said
hey man you can't wait for everything to
be perfect to start living your life
you can't wait for everything to be
perfect
to start living your life
and that hit me
I mean he packs a powerful punch and
that Ma he Nami hit me with a damn word
punt you know what a word hook
because I've I've been that's what I've
done
my whole life has been like that
inside of me it has been as soon as it's
all lined up I'm gonna show you myself
as soon as I've got it all looking the
way I want I'm gonna show up for you
and for me
and man those were just powerful words
that hit me this year
and I'm not trying to preach at you or
anything I just you know I was thinking
the other day about
what has been kind of a a highlight of
my year something I heard this year
um what are some things that
that stuck with me
and that was that was a big one
he sent me a message and he said and
sometimes you have to shoot a friend
straight
there's a lot of time where you can sit
there and you can be that shoulder
but sometimes you got it you know
you got to be that fist baby
and I'm not talking you know but active
I'm not talking homosexual uh
you know homosexualizing
I'm talking straight being straight
or being gay but I'm talking about being
a friend
I can't wait man
it's not all gonna I'm never gonna get
to that where everything's okay
where everything looks a certain way
and in the meantime I'm burning the best
time I do have available
I'm burning that candle up
I'm burning this candle down and I'm
saying as soon as it gets bright enough
or warm enough in here
I'ma show up
but the candle is getting smaller
it's a trap
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one